[Music]
well
you guys we have another am i the
[ __ ] here i love
these let's laugh at society
let's jump into this one okay it should
be called
delusional or nah validate me or nah
this one i think is actually like it's a
pretty good one
okay like a 50 50 like or no i think
it's a clear answer but
here we go so it says when i was in
college i got pregnant with my now
husband's child
we weren't ready for a child so we gave
him up for adoption at birth to a lovely
older couple that seemed like an older
version of us
we kept it as an open adoption and we
are not embarrassed about it
fast forward three years and we
graduated college and we
were about to get married the adoptive
parents informed us that he had just
been diagnosed with autism
we had them at the wedding and
everything seemed fine maybe he was
delayed but nothing serious
the adopted parents started to pull away
from us after we got married
visits and letters were decreased by
their choice three years after that my
husband and i had a child of our own
and my husband got in an accident that
gave him severe brain damage
my husband went from being an engineer
to having a mental age of eight
about eight or nine years old oh my god
he isn't able to remember things well
and cannot work
while he can use the bathroom on his own
and physically do his own hygiene he
needs to be reminded
in many ways he's my second child he
can't be on disability unless we
divorced
which would cause more problems than it
would solve like insurance and power of
attorney et cetera
so i am the sole support for the
household
the adoptive mother reached out this
year and is begging for help
the adoptive father died of a heart
attack and she's scared that she will
die
and her son will be all alone nobody in
the adoptive
extended family will take him because of
his extensive needs
his autism is apparently very severe he
can't speak or use the bathroom and
mostly communicates by screaming he has
very expensive medication and therapies
he really really needs
a stay-at-home parent because he is
often sent home from school early
i in no way can take this kid in i'm
already essentially a single parent to
two kids i have no time
or money to pile this kid's needs on top
i have to work long hours and can't risk
my job with constant absences i declined
and now she's constantly sobbing to me
about how
everyone rejects her son and when she
dies he'll just be thrown out like
garbage because
even his birth mother doesn't want him i
really can't do it am i the [ __ ]
edit it's been eight years since the
accident this kid is now 14.
i would say can they move in together in
teamwork
yeah i don't know that's a that's a good
suggestion that's a pretty good
idea you don't want to move in with
somebody who's like you're abandoning
your son
true you don't want to live in four
walls and also just bringing in
like more issues that she's already like
dealing with
and even they move in and then the
adoptive mother like passes away because
it seems like she's kind of at the end
of her rope as well
then you mean like she's gonna commit
suicide no it seems like they're old
how old i don't know but just the way
she's painting it is like
they're very old like very much older
than i
think that teamwork makes the dream work
but then what if she ends up i wish you
were on the phone with her and like
good luck all right who's next
like a joe hotline that's all he's got
he's got things that rhyme
good luck to you people like my quotes
yeah you take it or leave it [ __ ]
[Laughter]
teamwork makes a dream work take it or
leave it [ __ ]
he's like this is a very successful
company
what's it called what's this company
called dreamworks
you might hear you might hear from some
lawyers yeah you'll probably hear me
because i make the dream work you know
fine paramount
paramount importance that you help these
people
well okay it's basically like this
person's venting and saying like what
should i do in this situation because
all she's looking for is like
i really want to like not
get my son back and and i don't want
them to bring him back well she's super
[ __ ] though
like she's got to take care of her
husband and her kid like she's in a
horrible situation can't even barely go
to the bathroom by himself unless
she tells them to and [ __ ] i don't know
dude i think the
lady that adopted the kid if she wanted
to
unload the kid back she's got to give
her something for it
there's got to be an exchange she's
basically saying oh
um nobody wants to take care can you
take her back can you take the kid back
it's
trouble right but then if you want
somebody to take a burden of yours you
have to give something in exchange you
got to go
i'll give you my inheritance i'm going
to die soon
uh it's about five hundred thousand
dollars it'll probably help you
get the right care for all like your for
everything that you need
it's in the everything is a negotiation
you can't just throw problems at people
because you don't want to deal with it
anymore so in that case
this old adoptive parent like yeah they
did the work of like taking the kid in
but they also wanted the kid that's
what's that's what's wrong it's like
yes you're doing something to help but
you also [ __ ] wanted a kid
you stupid [ __ ] and then now all these
problems happen because legally
like that's that's the the adoptive
parents
are the parents period yeah there's no
refund on kids like
do you like a period it's a comma you
stupid [ __ ] yeah
you're right and then period no
exclamation mark thank you explanation
no ellipses here exclamation mark
question mark exclamation mark yeah that
could be oh that cleans it up a little
bit i'm pretty confident though she's a
[ __ ]
that seems like a capital b on that one
too the biological mother or
the adopted one she's like my life's
hard now i don't want this
responsibility
yeah what do you guys think the right
thing for her to do is give her
something
for that exchange i think there's only a
good team or a bad team here
and there's no nuance whatsoever so yeah
i think
by the adopted mother's a [ __ ] and then
we'll move on yeah
not the [ __ ] yeah i mean that's a
difficult
situation to be in that's the roughest
thing i've ever heard yeah what about
you anthony
what are you thinking yeah it's saying
it's it's just a really
it seems like a really sad story but i
mean
ultimately if i'm trying to think of
even like the
positivity that's going to come from it
it's like sure the husband
that that's that's a hard thing to deal
with for like the rest of your life as a
responsibility as well you know
taking care of an adult who has like the
brain and child of a child but
also your child that child will grow one
day
and become hopefully a responsible adult
that also hopefully with compassion will
help
the mom take care of the father and
stuff you know
upon the bernard on the kid i mean
you're all part of the family so [ __ ]
the family i'm
running damn on the contrary though i do
think like if the
the kid is uh has autism right and if
the dad
has uh brain damage then i feel like
they would actually
they could possibly really good be
really good playmates that's right which
might actually help with alleviating
like
the the necessity of like can't they
psychically communicate or something
like you know
yeah they they would they would
understand each other no the dad would
be the big brother he's like eight
yeah yeah but like i guess what i'm
saying is like i think uh
when you when you have a kid right a lot
of times that
the kid is needing you to just play with
them you know be there with for them
right and not just like feeding and all
that stuff is you know required but like
the play time is actually very important
yeah so
getting a grown-ass man that can throw
this [ __ ]
14 year old kid when they play baseball
or whatever
it's like that's dangerous 14 year old
is technically going to be the more
mature older one right
mm-hmm but depends on how severe the
autism is right
yeah but i guess my point is like when
having one child is actually very
difficult but if you have two children
she already has two children we're
fantasizing she already has children she
has more children than we're fantasizing
about
this eight-year-old dad playing with
this other autistic
adopted kid right now i think they
should just get him an xbox uh
and then the dad will kind of take care
of himself and
yeah also good advice for me like i'm
i'm torn because
logically it would it would make sense
that like she can't take on another
kid right but then like emotionally i'm
like oh but
that's your first kid though that's your
first kid
she's a down-ass [ __ ] i know and i'm
like oh i i don't know like if i was in
that position like i would be so
heartbroken
not being able to take in that's why you
get used huh that's why you get used
not anymore joe yeah but i'm just saying
okay emotionally i don't think i can
handle it all right
i'm gonna have a lot of guilt on my mind
and i'm just gonna be like oh my god my
first son is out there and i
i i can't take care of him and the
person who's like taking care of him
won't be able to take care of him i just
realized i didn't want to offend anybody
um so you could also get a playstation
too and not just
but that's expensive dude really
consider it man
no there's a lot i mean you i guess
switch too but yeah just wanted to clean
that up
pc gaming pc uh i just want to include
everything all platforms
the comments on this post here they
obviously
they ruled her as not the [ __ ] and so
there were some people saying like
no you know the adoptive mother it's her
responsibility to figure it out she
needs to find
who's gonna be able to take care of her
son and also
there are a lot of services available to
to help
and so like for example one person that
commented they said that they
have a an autistic child as well
and that they get they get free like
child care service with someone that's
trained
to to handle their child's autism
and that's like provided like it's a
free service that that's provided
through the government i don't know what
program but that there are resources out
there for the adoptive mother to turn to
and figure out like who's gonna like is
he
probably gonna need to go to a facility
that can better handle his needs and
then maybe the
the biological mother can can actually
visit
the sun and then maybe tell the adoptive
mother like hey i'll still be in his
life somehow i can't
take him on but i'll still be there for
him so you don't have to worry about him
being
dumped or like thrown away so that's
what the cause didn't say anything
there about how the dad and the kid
might hang out with each other and
probably i didn't read them all
the playstation i think we found some
solutions that are missing here
[Laughter]
two dogs are better than one uh that
that makes me feel a little better i
feel like i
i would be like if i was in a position i
would be that lady writing that post
because i
would have no idea what to do because
you gotta just ask me
you don't need to go on this [ __ ] i'll
tell you okay good luck [ __ ]
yep no i'm not going to tell you i'm
going to tell the other [ __ ]
hey you wanted it keep it i think we
figured this thing out from beginning to
[Music]
end
[Music]
so
you